ça fait un petit moment que je l'attends
ils viennent d'arriver le programme de
la journée c'est de les ouvrir les
configurer surtout de partir très
rapidement pour regarder les nouveautés
qu'il y a au niveau de la photo de la
vidéo parce que surtout il ya des
grosses nouveautés ici au niveau de la
photo de la vidéo on a une nouvelle bus
c'est la 15 et 7 plus elle vous permet
quoi d'avoir plus de performances donc
plus de capacités de calcul donc plus
vite pour les jeux le traitement et
compagnie vous permettra d'aller aussi
plus loin au niveau du traitement photos
et vidéos et vous donner de nouvelles
fonctionnalités donc ça c'est ce qu'on
va regarder ça vous permettra également
d'aller plus loin au niveau de la
batterie parce que qui dit meilleur plus
d'une meilleure performance d'une
meilleure gestion de la batterie
l'autonomie donc ça c'est aussi un point
qui est super important est qu'on va
regarder ensemble vous avez le stockage
qui est doublé au même prix une au coach
qui est plus petit mais ça va regarder
aussi dans quelques instants nous on va
regarder on va comparer par rapport à
l'iphone 12 pro mal ce que j'ai ici un
taux de rafraîchissement de 10 à 120
hertz mais ça c'est uniquement sur les
modèles pro un écran plus lumineux au
monde jusqu'à 800 litres eyeos 15 bien
évidemment et puis plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités sur la photo et la vidéo
mais s'en va seul et détaillé ensemble
mais première chose à faire on va
s'ouvrir c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
est réalisé en partenariat avec
rhinochill d'alors rhinochill vous
propose des coques pour beaucoup de
téléphones mais aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer sur l'iphone 13 min l'iphone
13 l'iphone 13 pro et l'iphone 13 promax
vous avez différents types de
protections vous allez aussi bien de la
solide suite à la mode helix à crach
garde qui vous dira personnaliser vos
codes vous avez plein d'accessoires on
va regarder dans quelques instants des
protections d'écran des câbles des
protections d'objectifs sony de suite
c'est quoi la sortie de suite c'est une
coque qui va venir complètement protéger
l'arrière de votre smartphone vous avez
différentes finitions des finitions noir
la finition unis blanc de la rose poudré
vous avez du bleu marine après vous avez
des matériaux vous avez le bois vous
avez la fibre de carbone le cuir noir le
métal brossé et vous pouvez même venir
les personnaliser à gaza truc que j'aime
beaucoup si vous avez des flamants roses
ou pouvoir des flamants roses ou de la
musique vous pouvoir de la musique vous
avez je sais pas combien de pages donc
je suis sûr vous trouvez votre bonheur
là dedans et en plus de cela vous avez
des collaborations avec plein de marques
différentes hello kitty batman league of
legends harry potter ricky morty friends
one piece pop corn je vous en passe des
meilleurs il ya le psg a fairy tale ya
la nba y'a fortnight vous avez aussi
libre qu'un sur la chaîne youtube on et
squeeze on à la nasa on applaudit paille
assassin's creed enfin bref y en a des
tonnes des tonnes et des tonnes des
tonnes vous avez même la coque de mon
pote job donc en a vraiment pour tout le
monde et pour tous les goûts et vous
avez également des modèles x vous avez
différentes couleurs de coques de
fonction de ce que vous voulez donner
comme style bien vous trouverez votre
bonheur vous avez aussi différents
design au niveau du verso on a aussi
retrouvé les crasses garde enix qu'on
peut venir aussi personnalisé au niveau
des couleurs sur le bord on peut mettre
du bleu on peut mettre du et on peut
mettre du rouge on peut faire ce qu'on
veut on est des fous vous mais venir
personnaliser votre coque avec un photo
collage dont vous mettez la photo de
vous ou de votre chat de qui vous voulez
peut mettre un texte aussi ça c'est très
sympa un marquage premium sur le back
home est un butin goreux mais ça
pourrait être sympa au jus de votre
famille ou alors un maillot avec votre
numéro et votre nom il vous retrouve
également des protections d'écran et ça
ne s'arrête pas là parce que vous avez
également des protections d'objectifs
protection d'objectifs photo en verre
trempé 9h pour l'iphone 13 alors
différentes couleurs vous avez la
couleur argent vous avez dû rouge et
vous avez également du noir ça c'est en
précommande donc si vous le dire
protéger votre appareil photo dans sa
peau est vraiment pas mal et vous avez
des câbles des câble tressé du câble
renforcé lightning d'art usb vous avez
du cab lightning aussi vers usb si vous
êtes toujours 5% de remise avec le code
greu 21 une fois de plus le lien est en
bas dans la description
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce qu'on a mis ici des
coques iphone iphone alors pour ma part
on m'a posé la question on m'a dit
aurélien qu'est ce que tu veux comme
iphone j'ai dit je veux un iphone 13 je
veux un iphone 13 pronax l'iphone 13 l
iphone 13 min et l'iphone 13 pro et 13
pro mac sont exactement les mêmes
modèles les seules différences que vous
avez c'est la taille de l'écran les
diagonales et la taille de la batterie
parce qu'on a forcément un peu plus de
place dans le xiii que dans le 13 min et
un peu plus de place dans le xiii tron a
exclu d'entrer spruce à 7,13 alors y'a
un truc qui a changé chez apple c'est
que comme il voulait plus les blocs de
charge eh bien ils vous mettent des
boîtes tout petit c'était déjà le cas
l'année dernière du coup pour la france
comme les écouteurs sont obligatoires et
vient au fond ces boîtes qui sont un
petit peu moche mais bon voilà on est
obligé d'y passer donc là vous avez vos
écouteurs à l'intérieur et là vous avez
autre iphone donc ça c'est l'iphone 13
et ici on va avoir le 13 promax aulas
j'adore ses nouvelles couleurs et il
faut savoir que l'année dernière pendant
toute l'année j'ai utilisé en guise de
téléphone perso et bien 12 pro mac je
puis vous dire que ça des téléphones que
je connais sur le bout des doigts pour
l'avoir tous les jours l'ouverture est
toujours très très très facile
walhalla cette couleur elle fait
vraiment mal aux yeux elle est vraiment
très très belle j'ai l'impression que le
système d'ouverture est différent je
pense que c'est qu'en fait apple change
leur boîte pour les rend beaucoup plus
éco responsable du fai vous avez plus de
petits papiers walhalla j'adore les
couleurs qui m'ont mis si regardez ça
c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper canon là
c'est brillant sur le 13 sur le 13 pro
mac c'est complètement matt peuple à 12
pro mac stress promax la première chose
qui va vous sauter aux yeux le module
photo est plus grand sur le 13 promax
que sur le 12 promax bon il est un peu
dégueu le mien foulée je nettoie mais on
voit vraiment que c'est beaucoup plus
grand dans cette partie là c'est aussi
un truc été mis en avant par apple c'est
que vous avez des plus grands capteurs
pour capter plus de lumière ça
permettrait d'aller plus loin au niveau
des conditions de faible luminosité et
compagnie avoir plus de détails avec le
xiii promax la dimension c'est
exactement la même le format c'est
exactement le même le tiroir de cartes
sim est un petit peu plus haut on va
regarder tout de suite maintenant avec
le xiii très très sympa alors il ya un
autre qu'il faut vraiment vous voyez qui
est super important c'est que l'encoche
est plus petit talent là il a éteint
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pour
venir modifier la taille de l'encoche
ces brasiers sur le 12 promax votre haut
parleurs étaient au milieu à côté de
votre caméra là il ya eu un agencement
qui a complètement changé votre haut
parleur est située sur le haut ça leur a
permis de gagner de la place parce que
si vous arrivez à voir en dessous là eh
bien vous avez trois capteurs au centre
et la caméra qui est sur le côté savoir
permet vraiment de gagner de la place en
fait faire ça comme ça l'agencement est
différent et on vient réduire la taille
de l'encoche tandis qu'avant vous aviez
deux capteurs là le haut parleur et la
caméra et à d'autres capteurs sur le
côté donc on avait un peu plus de place
hello you sa série es15 vous avez un bon
jour dans toutes les langues c'est
rigolo ya quand même une vraie
différence au niveau là tu es de l'an
prochain on vient gagner un peu sur les
côtés malgré tout les reste l'encoche
hâte que apple à voir dans quelques
années quand nous faisons un système de
faith heidi planqué sous l'écran bon là
je vous le dis on n'y est pas encore en
tout cas le bénéfice n'a pour l'instant
on voit qu'on est dans koch qui est un
peu réduite donc là on a un nouvel
iphone qui est pour l'instant
complètement nu que j'ai pas configuré
je parie mes applications histoire
partir directement commencé à venir
ajouté un peu ensemble on va aller voir
ce qu'on peut faire ici au niveau de la
photo au niveau de la vidéo c'est
vraiment une première prise en main il
ya le test qui arrivera très bientôt et
pour l'instant on va sortir et on va
aller voir ce qui se passe
ce film tout avec l'iphone
il faut pas pousser à écraser on va
regarder un petit peu ce qu'on peut
venir c'est en vidéo quelles sont les
différences qu'est-ce qui va fonctionner
question d'impressionner et on en
parlera plus tard lors du test à c'est
vraiment une première découverte donc
tout est filmé comme ça et on va les
scot est pas mal expliqué du monde
celle à 0
tu vas voir notre vidéo que la matière
et c'est ce qu'on appellera le mode
cinématiques sont configurés oui ça
reconnaît les visages alors on peut
faire avec cette caméra mais on va faire
également les caméras de celle ci donc
là je lance mon enregistrement ça c'est
moi et si je puis derrière je fais focus
derrière sur l'immeuble
c'est non
voyez à plusieurs trucs là j'ai fait un
verrouillage ci sera puis la
verrouillage auto focus donc c'est que
sur ma tronche
j'appuie derrière je suis sur la
personne d'ailleurs j'ai choisi mon prof
a choisi mon focus ou est ce que je veux
le faire donc là j'ai ma vidéo qu'est en
train de tourner et après je peux faire
ça en post prod mais je sais pas comment
ça marche modifié voilà c'est ça en fait
regarder l'âge et les points là dans ma
timeline ou je vois les endroits où les
points ont changé et je dois pouvoir
lorsque je suis un endroit pour manger
tout le monde cliquer sur lui voilà le
fond puis si cela ensuite je reviens je
clique sur moi il a ça fait un point sur
moi je fais ok c'est hyper hyper simple
en fait un bond il se découvre là donc
c'est vraiment hyper les personnes donc
ça c'est le mode cinématiques qui
marchent en scène filmée qui marchent
également de l'autre côté bien
évidemment alors foncez regarde pas
filmer non plus les gens mais voyez s'il
veut faire sur l'herbe devant jouer sur
l'herbe je veux mettre derrière sur les
arbres attention le seul truc voyez
c'est quand ça me capte des visages ça
récupère focus directement sur les gens
comme ça qui va faire une photo d'un
nouveau modèle des filtres jeu ici et je
veux venir retrouver mes filtres donc là
j'ai le fil dans ce temps-là contraste
intense six immenses est très contrastée
c'est quoi ça sert this show
3 alors là je choisis en fait et après
se modifier les tons c'est pas mal comme
ça c'est pour le ton et des températures
ce qui fait que en fait je deviens
complètement customisée l'expérience
alors l'idée du substrat qui l'habite où
il restera tout le temps posé là ce qui
fait vous allez pas pour amener à
changer vous êtes toujours sur le même
filtre donc ça peut être un petit peu
relou n'oubliez pas de venir changer si
vous voulez pas toujours avoir ce même
filtre là parce qu'il va s'appliquer
lorsque vous allez à faire toutes vos
photos ça c'est truqué aussi important à
savoir autre truc c'est que j'ai un tel
objectif avec un zoom optique x 3 garder
la qualité là même un contre-jour
sacrament pas ça me crame rien
c'est quand même vachement bien
vachement bien donc là hop là je sors
mon grand angle zoom optique x 3 et je
peux monter en x 15
bon après forcément la stabilisation est
pas là et pour la vidéo comme ça ça
marche
donc là je suis en fois je perçois de
croix
sur l' ultra grand-angle là typiquement
ici c'est un lieu ultra grand-angle
parce que j'ai pas de recul ça marche
super bien la caméra de celle qui s'est
pas mal mais c'est moi ça au niveau de
la qualité
regardez ciel niveau de la plage
dynamique en un peu plus de mal on n'est
pas sans même capteur clairement le
traitement c'est pas le même là il ya
vraiment un focus sur mon visage pour
que ça marche pour ce soit net
chercher mais
il ya tout nouveau mode c'est le mode
macro qui fait quand même ans et je me
rapproche la regarder la paf on le voit
la transition regardez là sur mon grand
angle et hop je passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle et là je peux m'en approcher
par la macro
c'est pas mal hein faut pas bouger mais
c'est pas mal
regardez le changement là on voit
vraiment pas ce que je passe de la lah
et surtout vous avez bien un accroc
jusqu'à 2 cm
normalement je peux aussi faire la macro
en vidéo se voir bien par là toi du coup
il déclenche pas automatiquement nommé
danseur automatiquement alors si je me
mets sur l'ultra grand-angoulême et
pourquoi je vais pas sinon c'est étrange
enfin grand talent je m'approche je me
rapproche de me rapproche pas si c'est
bon à jouer dans notre
moyen oient la maj ces normes qui dit
plus grand capteur dit forcément plus de
luminosité donc c'est sûr que tu es
iphone et connaissant avec ltd iphone on
va voir tout cela très très très bien
marché déjà quitterait bluffé un
partenariat ça marche bien je vous le
dis ça fait plus de vingt deux ans que
sur les iphone donc bon on utilise dans
tout le temps même si j'étais disponible
sur iphone je suis vraiment très très
satisfait de la qualité derrière donc là
je sais que derrière avec ce raid promax
toute la gamme 13 ans ça va vraiment
vraiment déchiré pareil pour les photos
nuit et l'on rentre un cadre à un peu
plus tard pas forcément faire des photos
ni tout de suite autre nouveauté c'est
le smart albert dans le smart thunder ça
nous permet quoi ça vous permet d'avoir
jusqu'à 4 personnes sur une photo avec
une optimisation de chaque personne
c'est-à-dire couleurs luminosité teinte
de peau aux textures bref la complète ça
c'est plutôt pas mal il ya un autre truc
qui s'appelle le début alors le
diffusion ça servirait à quoi ça
servirait alors ce que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de lumière à prendre plusieurs
photos ça va les mettre les unes sur les
autres pour vous sortir le meilleur
résultat complètement optimisé pour les
poteaux nous on a le mode cinématiques
aimant mais je reste un peu sur ma faim
c'est que c'est que
la vraie prendre on n'ira pas bien loin
il va peut-être falloir un peu plus de
performances on sait rien aux iphone
peut-être plus tard et puis surtout du
mode progresse on va devoir me rechuté
en françaises d'exporter facilement dans
final cut killer en vrac on se destine
vraiment vidéaste mais une fois de plus
ça arrivera un peu plus tard dans
l'année pas sur un iphone 14,2 sur
l'iphone 13 mai je penserai le temps
dans le temps qu'ils finissent les
ajustements ça arrivera tous ces
nouveautés on en reparlera bien
évidemment plus tard pour l'instant vous
laisser un petit peu de temps gelé l'âge
le test on regarde ça y'a plaque soldats
racontez-nous votre iphone c'est
vachement bien j'aime bien ce que
propose un policier on va regarder
toutes les parties photo j'aime bien
plein de photos j'ai eu plein de vidéos
ils grémont retour complet pour vous
dire s'ils sont intéressants s'il faut
switcher s'il faut attendre si les
iphone très intéressant pour moi il va
vraiment à lui axé sur la photo et sur
la vidéo on voit qu'il ya un gain de
performances dont font tout ce qu'il ait
divertissement micro promotion' le sens
verte ça va être vraiment pas mal pour
tous les passionnés guérit maintenant la
question c'est que bien il n'y a pas de
jeu encore ils sont vraiment 120 hertz
il va falloir attendre que les éditeurs
adaptent leur jeu pour ce soit
intéressant pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore le cas voilà pour cette
découverte aux iphone 13 pour le stade
sam gold coast ou leurs process que vous
pensez vous pourriez succombé est ce que
vous pensez vous pourrez vous laisser
tenter par un décret ce très gros match
comme celui là ou alors pourquoi pas 13
min quelle équipe parce que vous situez
13 min raise grèce trop 13 pronax vous
marquez tout ça en commentaire nous on
s'en va très rapidement
sur le test complet il y aussi les
iphone qui arriveront un peu voici un
peu plus tard il ya pas nous aussi
arrivant du côté du chien au mieux
encore des choses à voir du côté de
samsung vous voyez il ya plein de choses
qui se profile c'est très très cool
voilà un débit d'eau